if you don't have that middle piece of
transformation then people have no hope
and so what are they going to do they're
going to try to normalize it they're
going to be like throw their hands up in
the air and say well I was just born
this way because they are not finding
any kind of power in their life to work
and transform them and deliver them and
help them when you're depressed should
you watch depressing movies find out on
this episode of LED live
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to another LED live
everybody today we're talking about the
topic of depression mental health and
you know it's not every day that you get
a chance to have a mental health
specialist in the room Mia Pyle thank
you for joining the conversation she is
a mental health consultant and yes I'm
also a coach and I train people on how
to recognize and respond to mental
illness and what they can do to make
sure a person is safe and I think that
this is a topic that we're gonna see a
lot more of this need in this specific
area I think if we're all really you
know honest with the information we're
seeing an uptick in in people either
identifying as having some severe mental
health issues but it's also alarming to
me that we're also noticing an increase
of things in the media that probably
aren't doing anyone any good right
exactly you know it's been exciting to
see that people are more open about
their mental health and to be able to
say that hey I have this problem because
we know that mental illness is an
illness just like any other illness it's
not something to be ashamed of and yet
definitely the media is taking it
certain platforms are taking it to the
extreme and it's actually becoming
detrimental to people yeah and you know
I I kind of look at it like uh you know
if you're depressed
um you know maybe you feel better like
or or you feel like identifying with
depressing movies
you know if like you just got through a
breakup a lot of people talk about
listening to music that's very like you
know depressing Depeche Mode or
something like that from our from our
old school day and age right right right
and I know that um you know people that
I've worked with because I'm a mental
health coach and I really love to be in
the coaching space I love coaching
especially because not that long ago
well years it's been years now I
remember having my own mental health
breakdown and not knowing that there
were simple tools that could actually
help me to get better you know and so I
really love that and it makes sense when
a person wants to listen to you know
depressing music and things of that
nature because a lot of times we do not
know how to express ourselves and so
that music is um there to give us the
words that we feel we cannot express you
know or to bring about that mood that
we're in and so it makes sense that we
want to watch it look at it listen to it
whatever we can we want people to hear
how we're feeling how can we get the
feelings inside to the outside so
absolutely and it's also kind of one of
those things that like we we are you
know we're wanting to connect with or
identify with whatever we're engaging in
if you don't care about that topic then
you're probably not going to watch it
but if you're like oh wow in this movie
this person's dealing with mental health
and I'm dealing with that too and so
you're going to gravitate to it but I
think they're putting the wrong picture
out yes absolutely absolutely and what
you're talking about is that idea of
relevance right and uh movie creators
they know that they know that
um if I feel that I can relate to this I
can connect to this I'm going to keep
coming back for more and more and it's
interesting because a lot of these
things can even become addictive right
and so I know we're going to get into
that but um definitely just the need to
be aware of what's actually going on you
know we talked earlier about stigma you
know a lot of times when you talk about
mental health people are like oh you
know if somebody says you know I am
battling with cancer a lot of times
people are going to bring you a
casserole right they're going to bring
you um they're going to check on you but
if you say that oh you you know I've
just been diagnosed with schizophrenia
for instance you may get no calls you
know people may actually start to
isolate from you we know even in
spiritual communities people think that
mental illness can be a sign of demon
possession or it's a sign that you know
spiritually there's something wrong with
you and so I think that media has tried
to get rid of that you know but now
what's happened is that they're making
it um glamorous it's becoming
romanticized and now it's becoming the
thing to actually have a mental health
problem or to have a mental illness
which is actually making people more and
more sick and more and more in need of
help are seeking the wrong types of help
in media so I'm glad you brought that up
because I have a couple of examples that
I I do want to show in in that same vein
and this last um I think it's only been
a couple of years now since the Joker
movie came out and that was one that was
praised for its dealing with mental
illness but did exactly what you were
talking about
taking the idea of mental health and
then sort of not really addressing it in
a helpful manner but but actually
fueling the stigma of it so look at this
article talks a little bit about mental
health and it says however since our
severe mental health conditions such of
psychotic illnesses remain shrouded in
stigma and are consistently
misrepresented and misunderstood
portrayals of Mis of mental illness in
film can perpetuate unfounded
stereotypes and spread misinformation
one of the more toxic ideas that the
Joker subscribe to is the hackneyed
association between serious mental
illness and extreme violence the notion
that mental deterioration necessarily
leads to violence against others implied
by the juxtaposition of Phoenix's
character Arthur stopping his medication
with and with his increasingly frequent
acts of violence is not only misinformed
armed but further amplifies the stigma
and fear so I want to talk about that
that's huge because remember we are
talking about relevance and so one of
the things that movies are doing and you
all do a great job talking about that is
how can this connect and so we know that
um mental illness like people hearing
voices people needing to
um you know having hallucinations that's
a very small pop people in the
population not very many I think it's
only like 2.1 percent of people actually
experience this in the population and
yet there are people that can connect
with it because we've most people have
seen someone talking to themselves on
the street or this idea that a person
stopped taking their medication and so
now they're experiencing of different
things and so people can connect to that
but now the problem is is the idea that
this is so prevalent and that it's so
prevalent because the media has
highlighted it and the idea that mental
illness will look just so that this is
how you're going to act when that when
in truth that's very inflated actually
you know and and so it doesn't have to
be like this is a really rare case that
these things would happen and yet it
looks like oh it's common because of how
it's being highlighted and and I think
the danger of like looking at this
particular character especially kind of
like thinking that oh well if you have
these kind of problems like everybody's
gonna like gravitate to that right I
often wonder does it plant seeds also in
people's minds that are dealing with
this like oh well this is what everybody
does so I'm gonna act out in this way
like I know it's a it's a you know not
true understanding but I also wonder if
if it kind of even works on that end of
the spectrum as well well I'm glad you
brought that up because when I think
about role playing right role playing is
actually supposed to be something very
positive in which a person learns how to
change or modify their behaviors by role
playing with another individual or
either having it modeled to them so they
can know how to respond in a positive
way but often we see a flip a lot of
times and you see this in the media
where people are actually being modeled
to on how to have aggressive behaviors
being modeled too on how to respond
inappropriately being modeled two on
what their mental illness should look
like and so definitely this is coming up
a lot and there's so much research that
is talking about it Mayo Clinic has
talked about it Cleveland Clinic has
talked about it and so I'm so glad that
we're having the discussion about that
it's not interesting that we're talking
about modeling behavior in terms of
helping like understand it or helping to
do that and we call these people role
models all the time I mean like
celebrities every celebrity is going to
tell you like I didn't want to be a role
model but I'm a role model people watch
what you do and then they can't quite
distinguish between fiction and reality
and but you're modeling this Behavior
absolutely and what can also happen is
that you have people misdiagnosing
themselves you know you haven't gone to
a professional to see you know what's
going on you may have some symptoms
which could actually have another
underlying cause but now I'm seeing
those symptoms portray Aid and a media
character and I'm thinking oh this is
what it's going to lead to or this is
what I'll become so either one thing can
happen where I decide not to get help or
not to tell someone because I'm afraid
or I start to act like what I see
because it's that pattern has been made
in my brain that this is what this is to
look like I think the biggest problem
that I see in all of this is no matter
which way it goes
you really
don't see the power of the Gospel having
an opportunity to play out wow you know
because when you when you put it out
there for and people view it as normal
right and they see okay well I have a
mental illness therefore this is the way
should I should act because the Joker
act this way or some other character act
this way
what about help right but and and what
is the gospel for right it's to
transform the individual right I was
listening to my my pastor this weekend
recently and he brought out a really
great point and that was
really good at the beginning and the end
of what the gospel looks like but that
part in between so what are we talking
about so in theological terms we
understand the justification part pretty
well we understand the glorification
part pretty well but in between is
sanctification that growing in Christ
process where you're actually going
through those steps and Christ is
delivering you transforming you and
creating you into a new person
that part is largely being left out in
whatever we see modeled in front of us
and that's what we need most that is so
powerful that you brought that out
because it makes me think about the
scripture that says by beholding we
become changed right and when I think
about sanctification I actually think
about psychological principles like I I
wholeheartedly believe that many of the
things that we do in mental health
they're coming from the Bible some of
them are definitely being you know
perverted you know what I mean but just
the even the idea of sanctification that
there's going to be a process that you
go through by which your mind is renewed
being transformed by the renewing of
your mind and how God is going to model
and he's going to show you these
different but modifications that need to
happen how you need to respond how you
need to think how you can come to the
place of thinking in this way and yet
Hollywood and different social media
platforms are taking that same principle
that same concept and training you how
to be I don't know what a word for
de-sanctified I guess maybe that's it to
be desanctified and now it's unfortunate
because mental illness really is an
illness just like any other illness just
like cancer just like diabetes and now
Satan has an opportunist is coming in
and using mental health to
um I think it's like a backlash you know
even a backlash to the church a backlash
to the church where people have perhaps
in their misinformation made people feel
that oh I am demon-possessed or I am
spiritually in that because I have a
mental illness not understanding it so
now Hollywood as an opportunist comes in
and says hey there's nothing wrong with
you that you're you're normal to be like
this and you don't need to get help you
don't need the gospel or any other
measure you don't even need um to go see
a therapist or anything like that just
be as you are and let people accept you
yeah it's the same you know Born This
Way kind of mentality that's pervasive
throughout Society but I think the
church in some ways is at fault and I
mean the church you know Christianity as
a whole right you go throughout history
if they're not preaching the gospel in
the right context and and what I mean by
that is you have to have that middle
piece if you don't have that middle
piece of transformation
then people have no hope right and so
what are they going to do they're going
to try to normalize it they're going to
be like throw their hands up in the air
and say well I was just born this way
because they are not finding any kind of
power in their life to work and
transform them and deliver them and help
them I want to kind of preference it
with you had made mention that you know
any sort of physical element cancer
things that you would you would not only
just use prayer to help with but there's
some real world things that you can do
to help increase your odds of helping
solve that right eat well Sunshine fresh
air doing some physical things I think
mental health is the same like it's a
good thing to pray for it right but it's
also you need to do the work see a coach
get some help those tools are there and
God has blessed us in this modern world
that we live in with a lot of
information about how the mind works in
Psychology and all those things so I
think you need a couple of those kind of
things together and and like you said
sanctification is the work in between I
think really to help with the mental
health there's work in between
absolutely and really that's what
therapy is really all about therapy is
about sanctification in a sense that the
idea is that I may be believing lies I'm
believing lies about my myself I'm
believing lies about God this is this
happening at um with Adam and Eve right
and this whole idea of the controversy
is God working out those lies that we
believe it's the same thing in therapy
what lies do I believe that cause my
behaviors to cause me to do things that
are not for me they're against me but we
also have the idea that born in sin
we're shaping an iniquity right and so
no one gets to say that you know because
I was born in sin my um the the
consequences of that are going to
Manifest this way so I'm not saying that
a person is sin because they have mental
illness I'm saying that the idea that
mental illness exists is a fruit of sin
and now it may look like for one person
that they hear voices maybe the
chemicals in their brain or something
that's happening for them
physiologically to their brain like
physically so there's an abnormality
happening of some sort they were born
with that right just as I was born with
the way that I look I didn't control
that you know and so the beautiful thing
about God is he produces all these
different remedies for us to actually
get help and for some of us you know you
may never be able to have a leg that's
the same length as the other leg right
but that doesn't mean you can't be
healed there can't be things that are
created to help you have a better
quality of life the same thing with
mental health the same thing and I know
this is controversial sometimes people
actually do need to take certain
medications so that their brain can do
what it is not doing because of how they
were born so in the Joker movie to swing
the conversation what you just said back
to what we what we just read in this
article it's interesting because there
are these things that you can do to help
with that but look at this what happened
in this movie this is what it said in
the article studies show the association
is exaggerated and people with severe
mental illness are more vulnerable to
violence from others than the general
population interestingly the Joker's
Earnest attempt to create empathetic
character with mental illness who who
writes the worst part of having a mental
illness is people expect you to behave
as if you don't and Contra this
contributes to the very Prejudice that
Arthur longs to evade so in the movie
they're trying to say
um you know people don't understand this
and and they don't understand me but
then look at how they treat that is you
know they kind of basically do the exact
opposite they're not helping right
they're adding to feel for that right
and it's such a um a contradiction
because they are right people who often
do suffer with hallucinations
um or some other type of situation where
it brings attention to them I'll put it
that way they are more likely to come to
harm than to cause harm and a lot of
times people are afraid like oh no what
a person is hearing voices they're going
to kill me they're going to become a
mass murderer and that's what the Joker
is actually portraying when in fact it's
it's the total opposite and yet he's you
know showing this image that this is how
it could be so that's a huge problem and
it actually keeps people from getting
help you know because it doesn't suggest
any helpful things to it right it just
adds this element of like well you know
people don't understand him so then he
went out and he did these awful terrible
things right exactly yeah that's the
kind of train of thought I was going
down which is tricky
um and I wonder about this on a clinical
level but
it's essentially being the victim right
and victims
are never responsible right for their
actions therefore nothing in their life
is controllable
and everything just just kind of happens
to them right and so it it makes me
wonder how all that plays out not to say
that you can control if you're born with
a chemical imbalance or something like
that you can't control that right
but just like you were saying you know
if you found out you had some medical
diagnosis and there was something you
could do about it would you do it right
some people would
because they recognize oh I have the
power to do something in my own life and
of course God can can work without your
power
you know if he chooses to but if you
have it in your realm and in your in
your right of responsibility to do
something should you do that you know
that I think that's kind of a big
question and all that if I can do
something about it should should I do it
or should I throw my hands up in the air
and be a victim and say well you know
what I can't I can't do anything
um it's it's it's it's kind of a tricky
line to to ride I love that you brought
that in and I believe you're totally
right this idea of victim Consciousness
right this idea that you know because I
have this situation there's nothing I
can do and it's the total opposite
there's so many things that a person can
do to be empowered if they are
experiencing a mental illness and
just in talking about victim
Consciousness it makes me think about
you know this triangle that people can
be on and um uh lend Forest she talks
about it in her work and I don't
Advocate a lot of things that she
discusses but this one is very helpful
the idea of the victim triangle is that
you have people on this triangle who are
helpers you have people who are victims
and then you have people who are
persecutors and so what you see
happening in Joker is that he's saying
well because you know I'm I'm like this
and nobody's helping me I'm going to
lash out and so he's showing that
rotation around the triangle you didn't
help me helpers and some of us who have
people in our lives that are battling
with the mental illness we can get into
that well I have to help them a victim
consciousness of being the uh superhero
I must be the superhero for this person
they can't do it and that's a problem
and then the person at the bottom victim
I can't do it who now becomes a
persecutor I'm gonna make this happen
I'll make other people suffer because of
it and so um it's really interesting and
you see this Paradigm played out in so
many different shows and Concepts in in
culture Jeffrey Delmer
wow that's I mean the fact that you know
we took a real world situation that's
probably a very
mine like a like a not very frequently
common right you know what I mean and
then and then it's like you this was not
a small watched thing on Netflix when
you look at this compared to all of the
other Netflix shows it was exponentially
more um people were watching this over
and over and over again which what do
you think about that like is it just
that our nation doesn't understand
mental health issues or why are we so
attracted to this kind of a thing at
this point right right that's true well
a lot of times
um I can say with the people that I've
worked with there's this big desire to
want to understand why you know why
would a person do something like this
what caused them to do something like
this how can I protect myself against
something like this happening to me not
realizing that this is a very minute
thing that happens this is this is an
abnormality you you know it's not
something that I need to prepare for per
se you know that this will happen and so
I believe with human behavior I'm not a
human behavioralist however with human
behavior you see that need to I've got
to look at this and pay attention to it
so that I can protect myself so I can
know what to do keep my children for
becoming something like this so you have
that element but then also and I know
that you know we're going to be talking
about the scare Factor as well like we
actually there are people that get
something out of being afraid you know
it's like the fear and then that Rush of
dopamine that comes in that oh I'm okay
now yes exactly a lot of people watch
horror movies yeah but I kind of I kind
of wonder about that I mean I could see
myself watching the Dahmer thing from
the perspective of its historical event
that I want to understand what happened
just like she said but what is the
emphasis of the program is it filled
with all these terrible acts that he did
in like demonstrating those and
recreating those or is it or is it
focusing on other things it's a perfect
example and I'm not condemning this I'm
just saying years ago Terry Benedicts
made a documentary on Desmond Doss and
it really focused on his life and the
and what he stood for in the heroics
right
years later they make a movie called
hacksaw Ridge well what's the focus of
that it's war and showing the brutality
of war and and like Woody was actually
experiencing and into and yeah it has
heroic so we're part of it and what he
stood for was part of it but it probably
wasn't the most emphasized part of it
right so you can get information
served to you differently and depending
on how it's served to you you will
respond right in a way that you know it
could be more healthy or less healthy so
it would have been powerful if the
Jeffrey Dahmer series maybe would have
designed in that thing a more you know
here's what should have been done here's
what you know what needs to be done in
this kind of a situation so this isn't
repeated or whatever but it was it was a
lot of focus on his details of what he
did we had one lady rightes who watches
our Channel and she said you know I
watched it and I was very disturbed
absolutely and then I started having
nightmares and she's like I feel like
you know things have gone really bad
since then
um it's an incredible amount of
desensitization when you think about it
because no one is thinking about the
families of the people who lost their
loved ones in such a terrible way we've
become so accustomed to people being
murdered terribly right and and in some
cases it's seen as funny or you know wow
look at how that happened but what about
the families of each and every person
that was killed by Jeffrey Dahmer like
to me it would have been more tasteful
to actually see the family members of
the survival like the surviving people
and how this impacted them and what how
have they been able to uh survive since
something like this has happened to
their loved ones and actually getting
into the clinical reason why this would
have happened answering those questions
that people have about this type of
situation versus you know glorifying the
gore and the and the mental illness of
him and making it you know this thing
that is very untasteful very painful I
think it's a barometer for society and
where we're headed I think our love for
each other is really waxing cold and I
wonder if these things are contributing
to you know sort of this desensitized
view of when these things happen it's
every time we get exposed to this in a
mighty way like this in a cultural sense
in our whole country or even the world
it's like you just next time it happens
it's going to be like ah yeah that was
kind of like that other thing and then
you know if that happens too many times
it's alarming where we could actually
end up right and it's programming too
you think about like even you know
school shootings and I remember being a
part of a a mission group they were
called naps and we were privileged to
actually respond to the Sandy Hook
shootings you know and when I say
privileged privilege to be there to
support families privileged to walk
beside them in their grief and to sing
and hug and pray with them and that was
very cathartic but imagine now you know
the because of the pl the publicizing of
how the school shootings happened how
they were able to make this happen you
see the patterns coming up again as
these um people who are deciding to to
to engage in this type of crime now
mimicking the same patterns and so it
really concerns me when we talk about
things like the Joker and Jeffrey Dahmer
that people are getting those patterns
and deciding okay this is how he did it
this is how I'm going to do it
yeah the seed planting of that there's a
lot of Articles
um I came across another one like why
horror movies exploit mental health and
why it matters
um you know if you guys have an interest
in that area in horror movies or
anything like that do a little bit of
research on this area because I think it
is really important to understand there
is a connection between this sort of
like warped view of why the psycho
killer you know is doing what he's doing
and I think it's really putting a a bad
image of their people that really need
help we're not really you know putting
any good ideas out there to actually
really help them there was another movie
that came out that I want to mention
that had a profound effect in mental
health that movie was called Avatar I
don't know if you've heard of this movie
uh it was one of the highest grossing
films for a long time
um and this movie was kind of
interesting because once people started
going and seeing it they didn't just say
it once they went back again and again
and again so it's it wasn't necessarily
something evil and people are getting
murdered and and those kind of focuses
um this kind of really added another
element of mental health issues where
people were walking out of this movie
going man my life is quite boring and I
want to be back in this movie and that
was having a profound effect watch this
this news clip and you'll see here a
little bit about that oh before we get
to that
um this is what CNN said James Cameron
completely immersive spectacular Avatar
may have been a little too real for some
who say their experienced depression and
Suicidal Thoughts after seeing the film
because they long to enjoy the beauty of
the alien world of Pandora so I think as
we're as we're seeing a mental decline
in mental health in in the in the
population the more that we see these
Fantastical like unrealistic worlds or
something like this I mean that that
potentially I think can add another
element to this watch what the news said
about this
check out this comment left on a fan
website here it is when I woke up this
morning after watching avatar for the
first time yesterday the world seemed
gray it was like my whole life
everything I've done and worked for lost
its meaning lost its meaning after
watching this movie that's what's going
on here call in want to hear from you
1-877 tell HLN joining me Joe Piazza
entertainment writer CNN.com also with
us welcome back our psychotherapist
Stacy Kaiser uh Joe you did some digging
on this
um how widespread is this phenomena
where people are feeling depressed and I
guess the way to in layman's terms they
see this movie and especially if they
see it in 3D they're really feeling it
and then their world is not this so
that's what's leading to the depression
in a nutshell it is indeed and I think
the depression is widespread enough that
it is an actual phenomenon there were
over a thousand posts on how to deal
with post Avatar depression on one of
the Avatar fan forums and that's just
one of many fan forums where people have
gotten together to talk about how they
felt just like that one commenter said
very depressed they felt like the world
was gray and flat after waking up after
seeing Avatar is the 3d effect that make
it that much greater make this world
that much more enticing and appealing
out on these glasses and James Cameron's
CGI effects
so good
actually trans
onto the planet Pandora so you take off
the glasses and there's a disconnect and
that's what's making people more
depressed okay so what do you think of
that like like it's not just horror
movies but it's actually putting these
even these ideas out into Society of
these perfect worlds perfect
environments that actually can have an
effect right and you know it's really
interesting because you know we are
faith-based people we are Christians and
so we know we have heaven right and we
are actually encouraged to think about
heaven and meditate on heaven we read
about heaven in the Bible and yet you
don't hear people getting depressed you
hear people being encouraged feeling
strengthened to continue on and yet the
reason that this is happening for the
people watching Avatar is one the brain
knows no different so here you have the
movies and you all do really excellent
work on this I don't have to go deep
into it but I love the work that you all
have done about the prefrontal cortex
and how it's being bypassed when you're
watching a movie and now your brain
knows no difference your primitive brain
is coming into effect and it's taking
all this information in without the
ability for it to be processed in a
proper way and so a lot of times that's
now what's being brought on is that
depression because your brain wasn't
allowed to process it and place it as it
needs to it just went straight in as a
reality when you're reading the Bible
what are you doing you're processing
you're thinking you are using your
imagination and your imagination is good
God gave it to us to help us to
um to heal and to and to create plans
and things of that nature and yet this
is a perversion of that power that you
have and then bringing in the 3D glasses
just as all you know Matt adds more to
it
I think it's almost kind of like Santa
Claus if I can say this right like like
you have this character that you know is
made up right right and so I think the
difference here is like in a faith-based
situation I actually really believe
heaven is real I mean this is not
something I'm walking away from this
going oh wow somebody made this up and
that depressing thought of like you know
I wish it was like that but I know it's
not and I think in this type of
situation you've seen enough interviews
with you know there's no Pandora you
know these directors wrote this got a
dream made this story up and so I think
most people are walking away from this
going I know this doesn't exist but you
just showed me a picture of something
that was amazing yeah absolutely
absolutely and and it's it's really hard
because you know your brain wants to
make sense of it it wants to know that
hey I can I can experience this but
on that level it can another element
that I want to throw into this monkey
wrench of of being influenced by media
is it isn't just movies right
um we've kind of done some work with
digging into social media the impact
that social media has
um even YouTube uh this is this
generation's Entertainment form really
uh in fact you talked to any young kid I
had a conversation with a kid this
weekend and I was showing some examples
of some movie clips and we were talking
about the spiritual aspects and he was
like I don't really watch movies anymore
yeah and then he named off I was like
well what do you watch he's like I spent
hours and hours on YouTube so this is
very alarming to me we've made YouTube
stars out of people that are putting
damaging even examples out into the
world one of them I came across was this
this um Cooney girl who is um I mean she
is
lookingly very unhealthy right but she
has millions of followers what do you
think of this right well this is really
serious I mean um you know she talks
about you know being thin and
dangerously thin and what you need to do
to become thin and look like her and the
best types of clothes to be like her and
you know I'm not here to diagnose it's
not my realm however um just looking at
the signs and symptoms which I am to see
is that you know this person is battling
uh with something right she is
definitely struggling and yet it's being
glamor glamorized right and that that's
the issue because now as she's Gathering
all these followers it's being
normalized that this is how you should
look this is good body image this is
healthy for you
um this is what you are to do and and
even they have something as we were you
know discussing this they're talking
about how mental disorders are
glamorized by social media and there are
even people they call it pan pan Anna
pan Anna which has to do with
um basically being anorexic and how it's
a movement to actually become anorexic
as though it's something you should
desire and we know the anorexia and
bulimia are both mental health issues in
a sense there's something going on that
the person is dealing with that causes
them to go into these types of behaviors
and things of that nature and so it's
really alarming to see how many young
people are being impacted by the the
images that they're seeing and thinking
that it's normal and that it's good now
earlier you mentioned there's some
studies in this area one specifically
that you brought up that I remember
before we kind of got into this
conversation
they have recipes yes and things talk a
little bit about that yes they actually
have recipes on how you can look like
someone who is with the pen and a
movement and if you'll look here you'll
see they actually have Commandments as
they call it which is you know for a
person who's faith-based it's just
really you know it you can see that it's
it's a problem to say that these are
Commandments but if you if you want to
be attractive if you aren't a thin
you're not attractive right number two
being thin is more important than being
healthy and remember these are
commandments so the idea of a
commandment is something you must do in
order to be right you know in order to
to have a happy life or to have a good
out outcome you need to follow these
Commandments thou shall not eat without
feeling guilty and so all of these are
huge Flags going off you know as a
person that works in mental health these
are signs and symptoms of mental illness
these are signs and symptoms that
something is not quite right if if as I
as a mental health first aider and a
mental first aid instructor was to see a
loved one
um doing these different behaviors than
my first protocol would be to hey I need
to get you to your primary care
physician I need we need to go and see a
therapist we need to find out what is
the root cause of your behavior in this
matter and get you help immediately
because actually this is a life and
death situation there are so many people
so many people that die from anorexia
and bulimia and yet she's showing it as
though this is this is a yeah
it's this is fascinating in light of uh
Taylor Swift put out a new music video
and I think they cut this part out
um for YouTube
but there's a scene where and Taylor
Swift is not a
large person right she she appears to be
pretty pretty healthy
um I don't she may if anything she
probably looks a little bit underweight
but anyway she steps on a scale and
there's like two versions of herself and
this the version that of herself steps
on a scale and it goes up and then it
just says fat
and then they totally she got a lot of
backlash from that and they totally cut
it from the videos I haven't gone back
to look and see if you know it's still
on YouTube that way but that's what I
was reading as it got cut and this was
in the last few days see now that's
alarming to me because YouTube if you
understand YouTube I mean we spend a lot
of energy putting material on YouTube
the top videos are music videos these
are not small amounts of people exposed
to these ideas this is hundreds of
millions of people that often watch
these not once two three four five six
seven times and so it's like sealing and
Searing into your mind of pictures worth
a thousand words so that's alarming I
think given the context
um
what it was essentially had two versions
of herself there one that was happier
and more carefree and the other was
depressed and that the depressed version
was looking on the gut on the scale and
it and it read fat I think it's her
dealing with her own mental struggles
you know and and you know if you spend
much time around women you know this is
very very common you know they just
hardly ever feel up to par with their
weight in that area they're just always
you know but what's sad is somebody who
clearly is not overweight that I think
that was the issue that puts that idea
out there then it's like people who are
maybe overweight are gonna look at that
be like oh she'd think she's that way
how do I feel yeah well it's really hard
because even this the discussion about
weight you know it can just evoke so
much like I remember even before
becoming a mental health coach
personally battling with weight right
and and and having this issue this idea
that oh I'm supposed to look a certain
way we know that a lot of culture plays
into you know body image and self-esteem
and culturally should if you look this
way this means that you're healthy and
if you don't I know even in my cultures
as a person from the south right
Nashville is a person from the south the
idea is that you should have really big
legs you know and a really big you know
everything and yet
um you know someone else in a another
culture I remember when I was going to
it was a support group meeting actually
and I was telling them that like oh man
I wish that I had this or that and they
felt horrible because they were like oh
it's actually that you should have
really small legs is actually what makes
you beautiful and and and that your legs
don't rub together and all of this is
really
um a problem because it makes you not
want what God is giving you you know and
who is to say that the way I look is
unhealthy or I think it's more about the
numbers right I'm not a doctor but it's
more about what is your blood pressure
like what is your mental health like can
you really look at a person and say that
they're healthy or they're unhealthy by
the way that they look but we know that
media is very key on distorting body
image many of the people that they show
are healthy or beautiful they're
actually pre-teens right they they're at
the very beginning of their Adolescence
in the sense of you know body image and
they they put them they put them in
heels and lingerie and say hey this is
beautiful and they're a good 10 11 years
old you know and so that's something
that I love that you all Expose and
bring out in your in the work that you
do
it's important to be healthy and then
let the rest work itself out
um Billy eilish is another one that I
remember seeing in a music video where
she I think has a song that talks about
ending her life right I think that's
just a bad bad idea to put those kind of
images out there and you know everybody
that you know maybe even was on the
fence or start it's just like you're
putting these seeds in their minds so
definitely all of these areas of of
glamorization
um those those areas I think we need to
be very careful with and as we as a
society I think we should feel
responsible when we're putting imagery
out there and somebody's reacting to
that imagery we really need to think
about what are what are people getting
from our art so it's interesting that
you say that because
um there's an article it's titled social
media is redefining depression and this
was published by the Atlantic and one of
the things that they talked about is
that people are saying things now on
Tumblr like oh beautiful suffering right
and this is
um the idea that a person who is
battling with anorexia you're beautiful
you're suffering you're suffering
beautifully right and they even talk
about
um it's okay there's there's a hashtag
that was going around saying so it's
okay for you to hurt me but I can't hurt
myself and this is glamorizing suicide
in the sense that oh you're powerful to
be able to take your own life right
other people are hurting you so you
should be able to take your own life
even things like I want to die a lovely
death right and this is like
romanticizing suicide and self-harm and
people are thinking of it in this way
um there's another one that you have on
there and
um just think about it I think suicidal
people are just angels that want to go
home like when you think about that it's
basically saying that it's okay for you
to want to end your life you're an angel
and you know it if you come to this
conclusion go ahead and do that when
research has shown us that a person who
has become suicidal
similar to cancer you're at stage four
in your mental illness you're it's
almost like organ failure in a sense in
terms of your mental illness it's not a
idea that oh I'm I'm an angel that's
going to go home
that's alarming and you know I think
that there's there's a lot of
responsibility that I I you know I I
don't know what kind of person is is
even putting these ideas out there maybe
somebody that's experiencing these
things and they're trying to you know
make sense of it and and you know think
of themselves as as an Angel going out I
would be more Disturbed if somebody who
doesn't deal with that put this idea out
into the world that to me is more
alarming than somebody who's actually
experiencing that so you know I mean I I
can I can see we need to help figure out
ways in in the public eye to to help
people get help not like fuel the the
actual issues exactly
um Justin Bieber was in the news I don't
know years ago and it wasn't even really
him that was actually promoting or
causing some sort of self-harm I
remember he was like smoking weed he was
quite young or something and so his fans
were like we don't want you to smoke
smoke weed Justin Bieber so this I don't
know where this trend came from but they
did a hashtag cutting for Bieber and it
was all about like cutting to get him to
stop and so you know it's it's not just
necessarily always the celebrities that
are doing that but some action that
they're doing is having a profound
effect on on the population right and
it's definitely an artificial setup you
know because oftentimes people who are
cutting are experiencing immense
emotional pain and it's definitely a
release for them to be able to cut in
some way or to feel like they are in
control of what's going on in some way
and so to now make it a campaign that
we're going to cut for Justin Bieber is
once again that social media distorting
what is actually happening when a person
is experiencing mental health and I just
wanted to highlight this you know some
some viewers may be looking on and you
know the statistics actually tell us
that one in four percent of adults and
approximately 15 percent of teens in the
United States actually engage in
self-harm the statistics also going to
say that college students appear to be
the group at greatest risk with rates of
cutting which range from anywhere from
17 to 35 percent so this is really huge
you know that means by that statistic
that means that there's probably someone
that you know as a as a viewing
community that is experiencing this and
we need to know how to deal with it we
need to know how do we address this
properly if we find out that someone in
our lives is actually cutting themselves
number one we want to understand that
people that are cutting themselves a lot
of times people say oh they just want
attention you just want attention and
that's why you're doing this but it's
not the idea of an intentioned Seeker
but an attention needer does that make
sense the difference and so if you are
working with someone who is cutting keep
that in mind not oh you just want my
attention so you're doing this but you
need my attention attention needs to you
need attention for whatever is bothering
you or whatever is happening
um for you that is really really
important we also need to understand
that sometimes a person who may be
watching this and you're cutting and you
want to stop but you feel like you can't
you want to understand that cutting can
actually become an addiction you know um
because you're releasing those
endorphins you know this kind of like a
euphoric feeling that can happen
um because your your body is working to
make you feel better after you get a cut
just like if you hurt yourself with an
injury and so addiction can even set in
for those who are cutting another thing
that we want to understand is that
people who cut may do so in phases right
like you may actually have someone who's
been cutting for a few years
and then they stop and then they can
have a relapse and so that's that's
really important for us to know and um I
just want to say this as well that when
you're going to address someone who is
cutting understand that it's not always
most times people that are engaging in
self-harm so I'm saying cutting but it
could be burning it could be you know
drinking something that you shouldn't
you know a toxic material and seeing how
far you can go we need to understand
that it's not always this idea that I
want to die you know a lot of times
actually cutting makes people feel that
the pain is going away and so when you
can understand that you can kind of come
from a position of strength on how
you're going to talk and work with that
person
so so I do have a question about the
cutting thing because you said it was
like 16 17 right right I had no idea 17
to 35 percent
what it what is what is how are you
getting this idea I mean I I remember
the first time I even heard about it I
mean probably a lot of people have heard
about it but
you know where where are they getting
inspired to do this and like what is the
real driving force behind this thank you
so actually I was studying about it as
well and some of the things that were
coming up is one remember our our
community can have an impact on us so a
lot of times people who are cutting
probably have someone in their life who
is also cutting and by cutting I'm using
that to also mention self-harm so if
there's someone in their life who has
done self-harm you're more likely to
engage in self-harm as well just like if
someone in your life has died by Suicide
um your risk factors go up incredibly
another thing is we think about our um
our social media right A lot of times
we're talking to people who are
interested in the same types of
information and so they have they call
it a um filter bubble where all your
information is in kind of like a bubble
right and so in that bubble if there are
people who are cutting then you are now
exposed to that as well if this is how
people in your bubble are dealing with
their frustrations or what's happening
to them then that's also able to come
your way so you mentioned you know
there's a this euphoric feeling or at
least a release people feel better from
doing this and I can't help but wonder
you know my mind's going back in history
and thinking about Martin Luther you
know before he discovered what
justification by faith was
he was inflicting self-harm upon himself
and I was you know kind of struck with
that thought it's like we don't probably
tend to think of it that way but he was
you know making himself go through
things whether it be lashes or you know
climbing steps a certain way and it's
just fascinating to think that you know
here he is in a religious context
searching for
um searching to relieve pain yeah yeah
and because he didn't have the right
answer at that time
you know I I know this might not be the
best of examples but the demoniac
cutting himself I mean you know we have
examples in the Bible of this happening
so I I wonder if you really had a real
true window into the past this is
probably just not just a modern right
setting this is probably something that
people have been doing for a long time
self-harm right and I and I want to just
bring this up it's important to remember
that a person that may be engaging in
self-harm it does not mean that this
person is demon possessed right and so
this man was the the demoniac he was
suffering from a mental anguish
emotional turmoil and a lot of times the
things that people are going through you
can't see it you know you can't look at
me and say my heart is broken I'm
grieving and so um being able to have
that Mark for some people that do
self-harm it kind of gives them a relief
that at least there's evidence that I'm
in pain because no one else can see it
or it's hidden you know
um and another thing I think it's huge
that you brought up um
Martin Luther was not possessed when he
was doing all these different things he
had a missed um concept of God those
lies believed that we talked about
earlier and this statistic didn't say
you know secular college students are
doing this this said college student and
so we know that there are people who in
who love God with all their heart but
they don't have the tools they don't
know about that they can actually do a
brain detox they don't know that
um there are things that they can do
that can actually relieve their symptoms
and they don't have access to those
things maybe because of stigma right or
what will people think which is also
stigma you know and they may not tell
anyone because of that to get the tools
that they need and so they may continue
engaging in their behavior so kind of
circling back to where we were at the
beginning of the show it was
a proper understanding of theology that
actually helped Martin Luther get past
that because once he understood the role
of Christ in his life right then he
stopped doing self-harm you know he had
a different a more he had the only
healthy solution you might say and so
it's just it's just fascinating you know
what what you think I've been wanting to
ask you I would imagine you have have
you read the book
um telling yourself the truth I haven't
actually I have not read that okay great
resource so since we're talking about
resources towards the end of this show
it's written by Christian counselor and
he really
um talks about how we tell ourselves so
many lies and I read this book with my
wife it's um it's actually if I remember
right it's a required reading or a
highly suggested reading for Dr nedley's
depression anxiety recovery program
right so
um we we read it together to better
understand our own you know mental
health struggles if you will and it's
amazing how many lies we go around
telling ourselves and and what's you
know one of the reasons we're interested
in it is we have a child at home that
does the same right thing you know and
they and we're constantly having to
remind them no you're loved you're
valuable the things that you're saying
are not true they don't have any
foundation in anything and
um but it really
um can I say I think I have nothing to
substantiate this on but I think
sometimes God allows these situations
for you to witness that you can take a
step back and observe it in somebody
else and be like oh wow like yeah I mean
I'm I'm constantly odd and as well with
things that my children do that I'm just
like I think I have a problem with that
you know
um so you know as parents I I would
imagine if your child is struggling with
these things you know sometimes maybe
it's good to take a step back and and
and understand do some understanding
read some books some resources
um but it may be something that maybe
also will help you down the road and I
want to say you know this is so powerful
that you're bringing that up as parents
I think one thing that can be really
helpful to us is to take the air out of
the uh bubble like deflate that this is
a issue and this is a problem and the
idea that there's something wrong with
you because this is um what Satan said
to even the Garden of Eden right he he
gave her the impression that she didn't
have something that she already had
right that she was less than that she
was not enough right and this this can
really happen for us as parents you know
we see some of the flaws and issues that
are in us in our children right and
we're like oh yeah you know but another
thing you know when we think about the
idea of telling ourselves lies these
cognitive distortions I like to
um let the people I know that I work
with know like hey normalize it on this
plane
everybody has cognitive distortions
everyone has lies in their mind that
they that that are there it's a part of
our human condition and there's so many
things coming at us from the media that
are training us to have lies believed
which is why we have to do therapeutic
things like having devotion and prayer
and mental health exercises that allow
us to step back and see that oh I can't
believe that I believe this like one
simple one is jumping to conclusions how
many people have you had a conversation
with that jumped to conclusions how many
people think that how many people do you
know that mine read right they think
that oh I know what you're thinking
because you made that face you know and
now we we create this whole story around
it you know how many people disqualify
the positive there there's something
something amazing about them and yet
they're disqualifying all the positive
things about them and this is just a few
you know I'm actually naming my own
cognitive distortions those are things
that now that I recognize the lies and
the patterns I can now when I I get into
a situation I can have positive
self-talk and I can talk to God about it
I can say when I say positive self-talk
not just you know oh I'm so good and
wonderful no right positive self-talk in
the sense that I can say Okay Mia you
are actually jumping to conclusions you
don't know what Scott is thinking you
know
um or positive self-talk God says I'm
fearfully and wonderfully made he says
that you know I have this treasure in
Earthen vessels that the Excellency of
the power may be of him and not of me
which means he knows I'm earthing I
don't have to present as though perfect
and everything's just all right he's the
one that has the Perfection and he's
going to grow me into that Perfection if
that makes sense that's sanctification
it's it's a powerful thought because we
are Society in general
wants us to to have this self-worth
right right but worth defined by self
isn't really worth a whole lot right
it's only worth that's defined by Christ
that's where worth anything and so where
we draw our worth from is hugely
important
you know and I don't think there's a
better Source than drawing it from
Christ you know and you want to know
what you're worth look at what the price
that he paid you know he he gave his son
and gave all of heaven and so that that
really tells us a lot we don't have to
look any further than that to know where
it is that our self-worth is but one you
did one of the things that this book
brings out and it was really talking
about scripture and how scripture really
reinforces the truth because it is God's
word and so if we want to know and
understand what reality is what truth is
then we need to be reinforcing our minds
with scripture because that is going to
tell us reality and going to tell us
truth and going to help us Define what
our worth is so yes I've heard it
described as like um you know we we went
we run around and we have like pieces
and bits of the information so it's like
blank it's like blank blank you know and
we're filling in the blanks right so if
we don't have something the truth to
actually fill in the blanks we're always
going to fill it in with the default of
like the worst thing right so you know
it's like yeah you gotta you gotta get
it from the source because they're
giving you the answers to why these
things are the way that they are right
and um just the the last thing I will
say is truth filtered through the right
lens because a lot of times people read
the Bible and you're reading the Bible
but you feel more condemned right you
actually feel more condemned and that's
because of Lies believes about God you
know Satan is always he he specializes
in using the word against you and so for
those people that may be watching
sometimes you're like well I'm reading
the Bible and I actually feel the worst
I feel like a filthy rotten Sinner and
I'm just disgusting and there's I feel
like I'm going to be the people who are
lost if you're coming to that conclusion
know that Satan is distorting he's
causing you to read and hear and see the
Bible from the wrong lens from the wrong
Viewpoint because everything that God is
saying in his word even when he's
correcting this even when he's showing
us our sins and showing us where we fall
short it's from a lens of love and I'm
going to help you I am going to empower
you if you will
this day you know if you will allow me
to to change you I can do it and now
when I read the Bible I don't feel so
condemned and I'm a terrible person you
know but I read that from a lens of I'm
I'm being diagnosed
and therefore the diagnoser can help me
versus I'm being condemned it's kind of
like shifting your your view of it of
like the Bible's just trying to tell me
everything that's wrong with me too it's
telling me what's wrong with me and
giving me the solution to help me you
know it's like right it's wanting to be
a help to me yes there's a verse in in
Psalm 103 I like what this says in light
of this conversation it says in verse 2
bless the Lord O my soul and forget not
all his benefits then it goes on to
enumerate those first thing it says who
forgives all your iniquities
who heals all your diseases and I I want
to say that's not limited to our
physical diseases but our mental and
emotional diseases as well so what are
some resources some practical everyday
resources that people can go to because
we've talked about you know anorexia
we've talked about General mental health
and how it's influenced by the media we
have talked about cutting what are some
resources people can go to if they're
struggling with these things right
awesome I'm so glad you asked that so
first I want to say because these are
really serious issues anorexia bulimia
can lead to your death right and if you
are definitely having auditory
hallucinations you know like visual
hallucinations these are very serious
things that can be helped and I want to
say recovery is always possible so the
first step I like to point people to is
their primary care physician because a
primary care physician a doctor can be
that person to let you know if this is a
physiological abnormality or this is
something happening with your mental
health okay and they can also refer out
they have the ability to send you to a
therapist a counselor and mental health
coaches I love being a coach because
sometimes people feel that the
traditional route of going to therapy or
a social worker hasn't been working for
them and the difference between a mental
health coach versus a therapist is a lot
of times we as coaches we can bring in
our personal experience when it comes to
helping a person and we have a little
bit more leeway and how we're going to
enter this environment okay another
resource that is really helpful is I
love okay so people should know that you
know everyone
doesn't necessarily need to see a
professional in the sense of I need to
see a therapist definitely the issues of
anorexia bulimia schizophrenia even
depression if you've been experiencing
your symptoms for more than two to four
weeks you definitely want to see someone
you want to see a professional okay
however there are people that can
actually get relief from doing things uh
just in nature for instance there's a
beautiful acronym new start that talks
about ways that you can actually be
better you can join a support group a
support group is amazing because they'll
have people with shared experiences and
they're talking about it in a safe
environment where you won't feel like
you're going to be judged right when you
say that I drunk something I wasn't
supposed to or I did something I wasn't
supposed to and a lot of times there are
trained people there to help if you're
talking about something that is painful
to be able to get you back to a happy
place if anyone is watching this or you
know someone and you're concerned that
they may be suicidal I want to share
this number with you and that is 988.
this number can be used to text or to
call so especially for young people that
may be in a situation you don't want
anybody to hear what you're saying but
you know you need to reach out to
someone you don't feel like you have
someone right around you then you
definitely want to dial 988 and that
person is trained to take you from a hot
moment to a cool moment you can also do
it via text they can talk to you they
can give you resources
some people may say you know Mia I'm not
at that point but I would like resources
how what what can I look into and so
there's also the idea of a warm line if
you want to talk to someone you can
Google Warm lines in your area and the
warm lines know that okay I'm not
suicidal but I do need help and so I've
I've used all of those personally and
been able to be helped and go on with my
day another thing that I want to share
with you is something called the brain
detox this is something that you can do
every day and imagine that I like to use
it for part of my devotion time okay and
I'll just explain it really quick it
basically starts off with today I feel
okay and so you write down all the words
how do you feel I feel good I feel bad I
feel fat ugly it doesn't have to make
sense it's just writing down
um your thoughts and then the next part
is your automatic negative thoughts are
ants right we know that if you have ants
in your house you can't just pray ants
away you pray and then you get a plan
and so you're writing down those and
which help you to identify lies that you
believe you know are patterns like
nobody respects me no one loves me
you're going to see a pattern as you're
writing down those automatic negative
thoughts coming to your mind why are we
doing this some people may say you know
if you're writing this down you're
giving the devil power he can see your
thoughts and he's going to act on it no
Satan studies us we already know he sees
the patterns you're probably feeling
this way because he's had something to
do with it you get what I'm saying but
another thing is we think about the
scripture which says take every thought
captive well how can you take something
captive that you're not aware of this is
why we write because research also tells
us that when you write you're telling
your brain your body I'm doing something
about what's bothering me so as negative
as your automatic negative thoughts may
be consider that it's like having and
I'm going to say this having a bowel
movement you know the bowel movement
needs to come out so that your body can
be healthy and it's the same with those
negative thoughts okay you don't just
end on negative though it's really
important that from there you have that
conversation with Jesus right you can
talk to him about what you saw in your
today I feel and your automatic negative
thoughts just just having a conversation
writing down you know God I didn't know
this was in my heart like I'm really
ashamed that I feel this way about this
person I couldn't believe that or you
know I need your help with this why is
this like this right and then understand
that a conversation is two ways we're
not just writing and not thinking that
God's not going to enter us he will
he'll send a friend to call you or he'll
bring a Bible verse to your minor you'll
see a sign somewhere that's God is
speaking to you he's letting you know
that he cares and then always always be
in with praise we always want to say
what are five things we're thankful for
and it can be more than that you know
I've done this exercise and had 20
things at the end of the day it can be
very simple you know something like I'm
just thankful that I this day is over
um
hey I hate to interrupt but we are
really out of time we we really need to
like close it okay we're wrapping it up
and so being able to just end with
praise and be thankful what are five
things you can be thankful for this can
be really helpful you can find it at our
website
paytonwayfit.org we have a free brain
detox on there for you you can use it
there Mia you are a wealth of
information I feel like we could sit
here for hours and hours and uh you know
we are literally like blessed by the
information that you're giving to us not
only in a practical sense but I know
that you've struggled with some of these
things personally so it's like what
better of a person to deal with it than
somebody that's been through it if you
guys want to check out Mia's website get
a hold of you look more into your
information where can they find you yes
you can find us at
payneunwaisted.org that's pain
unwaisted.org we'll put the link in the
description below but thank you guys for
watching and tuning in on this week's
LED live and we hope that you were
blessed by this information remember God
loves you we love you that's why we're
putting this information out to you we
want to hear your thoughts if you like
this video please give it a thumbs up
that helps more people see it and our
goal of doing this information is
getting this information to the people
that need to see it so if you want to
share this information with somebody
please feel free to just send them a
link that can be a form of a Ministry
and thank you so much for for supporting
us in your prayers and your thoughts if
you want to jump on check out our
patreon that helps us produce more shows
like this and as always if you have more
ideas for us or things you want us to to
cover in the future we want to hear
about it so please communicate with us
look up our our ministry on Facebook
Little Light Studios and we hope that
you are blessed we'll see you next week
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you